from the creators of dark comes 1899 or
as I like to call it the amount of times
I went what the hell
in this video we'll be taking a look at
some of the show's Biggest Mysteries
where it might be heading in season two
and of course all its nods to Titanic
I've left timestamps below so you can
see all the topics we'll be covering
without further Ado let's get into it oh
and uh like And subscribe the year is
18.99 at least that's what we think it
is Maura Franklin is aboard the Kerberos
and newly refurbished ship headed to
North America along with over 2 000
passenger and crew we immediately learn
of her missing sister ship Prometheus
which vanished over four months ago
Prometheus not only the name of a Ridley
Scott film was a Titan from Greek
mythology who defied the gods by
stealing fire from them and giving it to
humanity in the form of Technology
knowledge and civilization as punishment
for this crime Zeus had an eagle eat
prometheus's liver he'd then regrow it
and have the eagle eat it again and
again in an endless loop similar to how
the passengers engage in their own
endless loop even weirder that the
Greeks believe the liver to be the seat
of human emotions and human emotions are
what Henry Singleton believes to be the
thing that keeps them in their Loop and
every time they die
because they can't get rid of their
emotions the second ship is Kerberos or
more commonly known as Cerberus the
multi-headed dog in Greek mythology that
guards the Geeks of the underworld to
prevent the dead from leaving our
Kerberos Works in a similar way
preventing our dead from leaving and
sticking them in an endless loop we're
told that these two ships along with a
mysterious third that is never mentioned
by name were bought by Maura's father
from a German company refurbished and
set out to see oddly enough the crew
think it's weird that there's apparently
any Freight aboard and the cabins are
only half full as we'll find out that's
because we're not on a ship at all
rather a simulation 200 years in the
future at the end of the season more
awakens to find herself aboard the
Prometheus not the 1899 version but a
futuristic spaceship housing what
appears to be every passenger we met in
the simulation this ship is composed of
dozens of pods which house at least 14
humans each in Maura's pod almost every
character here received mysterious
letter which set them on their Journey
aboard the Kerberos Morris for example
was from her brother he wanted to meet
her in New York where he's found out
something nefarious their father did
Maura's brother's name is Kieran which
is odd since it's an Irish name meaning
little dark one not ominous at all and
in episode 2 Daniel states that while
Maura is an Irish name she herself is
not Irish it's just an odd thing for the
writers to bring up if it weren't
important for the story I actually have
a theory that Kieran isn't a person at
all rather an AI set to transfer
humanity and only awaken them when
they've learned to choose a reason over
emotion remember what Henry said these
humans will continue to die in the
simulation because they can't get rid of
their emotions we know from the computer
monitor that the Kerberos is on a
survival Mission perhaps Earth was
destroyed due to Humanity's emotions
something Henry calls man's biggest flaw
thus the Prometheus was created to fix
this problem to re-engineer the human
mind so that it will always choose
reason throughout the entire entire show
the simulation has been a metaphor for
the human mind so maybe that's what this
is it's some kind of imitation of the
brain and the different areas are
connected to each other all the areas of
the ship the passengers memories and
Asylum are connected through a series of
literal electrical Pathways just like
our brains which connect our memories
Daniel can change the code of the
simulation cannot the coding of our
brains be changed as well Maura finds a
letter for her on the ship's console
which reads mayor Coffee Kick in before
reality does this is the same message
written over and over again on all the
nautical books from the bridge and I bet
they'll need some coffee looking at all
those weird veins on their faces my best
guess is this is the result of being
tied up to these machines for so long
maybe they were even injected with
something there were also some
coordinates but these are different than
the coordinates found in episode one and
I'm not quite sure what these
coordinates will do in space we also get
the date October 19th 2099 which is
exactly 200 years from when Mora awoke
in 1899. we do get a message from Kieran
stating welcome to reality which leads
me to my next big topic what is real in
episode 7 Daniel brings up Plato's
allegory of the cave picture yourself in
a cave and you see Shadows dancing on
the wall you believe these Shadows to be
real you're seeing them right in front
of you when in reality something behind
you is actually projecting these images
who is to say that what everyone's
experiencing here isn't a projection or
simulation that also begs the question
are the events in space even real is
this a simulation within a simulation at
this point in time we just can't be sure
in episode 8 Henry tells his daughter
that she was fascinated with this
allegory as a child she became obsessed
with the idea that our knowledge has no
limits and we can never know if things
are how they truly appear we're in a
slumber unaware of the true nature of
things just like our characters are in
their own Slumber Mora believes reality
is simply neurons flying around in our
brain and that never know
bye
a reality or a construct of one what we
do know is that the events in 1899 are
not real they Loop over and over again
over a period of eight days if we're to
believe Henry this was a simulation
created by Mora so that she could be
with her dying son Elliot but something
to me doesn't really add up here it all
seems pretty convoluted to create all
this extra stuff if you just want to be
with your son Henry even goes so far as
to refer to the simulation as Mora's
dollhouse and that Mora is God a creator
of this reality but then it also begs
the question if God is merely the
creator of our reality then who created
God doesn't it go on endlessly as we
know the passengers are stuck in a loop
this has gone on dozens of times each
Loop taking roughly eight days and the
old simulations archived in a graveyard
of ships we don't know why this Loop
occurs but we do know that Henry wants
to keep it going and Daniel wants to
stop it Daniel believes the key to
stopping the loop lies in Mora the only
problem is that Mar has no memory of her
past life for most of the Season we're
led to believe Henry wiped her memory
when in fact it was Maura herself she
was purposely hiding the very key that
would get them out of there but why
Henry believes it so that she could be
with her son regardless Daniel wants to
snap them out of this Loop and come back
to reality if you notice in the
spaceship scene we never see Daniel or
Elliot are they awake on that ship the
two of them seem to be Rogue actors free
from the normal constraints of the other
passengers in fact when we see the
spaceship scene there are two already
opened pawns one that Maura just came
out of and another by the window could
this belonged to Daniel Elliott or
someone else entirely after all Daniel's
last words to Mora is that he'll be
there when she wakes either way Daniel
says the key to overriding the loop is
somewhere with Mora we'll later find it
hidden away in her locket if Mora
created this simulation simply to keep
people trapped there then why would she
carry with her such an easy way to
escape it it's just further proof that I
think Henry is hot hiding something
Maura's key fits into this small pyramid
device by unlocking it this simulation
resets this is why Henry so desperately
wanted to find Elliot because he had it
the device can also manipulate time
within the simulation in episode 5 we
see how Elliot uses it to stop his
mother from being shot a larger pyramid
also acts as home for Daniel and Maura
perhaps this is why she chose it as the
override device Henry successfully
steals the object from Elliot but when
he uses the key it doesn't work that's
because Daniel has manipulated this
simulation's code so that the key no
longer works for that pyramid rather a
new one and this new pyramid requires a
new key her wedding ring and a pyramid
is also just a great metaphor for
Secrets as many of the ancient Egyptian
Pyramids held secret treasure throughout
the season we've seen this green beetle
which can seemingly unlock any door if
we're in a simulation consider the
beetle a metaphor for a back door able
to get into places others can't in
episode 8 we learn of its origin Elliot
found one and wants to keep it but his
mother says it probably wouldn't want to
be trapped in a prison like that she
even says sometimes we have to let
things go because we can't keep them
forever this doesn't seem like a woman
who's keeping prisoners trapped in a
simulation Elliot however says I live
with you and Danny forever I don't know
I get pretty weird vibes from that and
knowing how the creators of dark love to
play with time travel I wonder if we'll
see a grown-up Elliot who knows how long
these guys have been in space and do
they age while connected to the machines
if so have Elliot and Daniel grown old
while Maura has stayed the same age in
terms of passengers we know from episode
8 that they're all here for a reason
each of them have some sort of emotional
trauma that they're running away from it
came on this trip because they made the
choice to forget their past now they're
all stuck in here as well a few of these
passengers we get to see how these
traumas unfolded however there are a few
exceptions and I want to talk about
those in the final episode Ling Yi
stumbles upon Olex trauma on the ground
next to a trail of blood is the same New
York postcard he carried around with him
all we really know about Olek is that
he's off to America to see his brother
at least that's what he says Ling Yi
will see him emerge from some sort of
tar or oil vat if any of you know what
that is please let me know maybe he
killed someone here speaking of murder
we also get a glimpse of Ramiro's trauma
in episode 3 we learned that he killed a
man and took his clothes I.E his priest
outfit that may explain the church in
the background Ramiro's lover Angel is
somehow involved in this we'll see
Angel's back covered in scars but we
never find out why my bed is that we'll
explore more of these in season two the
last person I want to cover is Henry if
he is actually Maura's father he's a man
fascinated with understanding the brain
he became obsessed with learning to
repair it after his wife's mental health
deteriorated something he blamed his
children for we also know he wants to
keep Maura in his simulation forever I
get the sneaking suspicion Henry isn't
the main villain here as Daniel warned
Mora this whole thing is so much bigger
than she can imagine 1899 has yet to be
renewed for season 2 but I really hope
it gets picked up because I need answers
if there's something I didn't cover in
this video that wasn't explained in the
show let me know in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember what the hell is going